[Musique]
je connais un homme dans une ville
bretonne qui était autrefois cadre dans
une grande entreprise privée
je connais une femme dans une grande
ville bretonne qui travaille dans le
bâtiment
l'homme dont je vous parle a perdu sa
femme et sa fille dans un accident de
voiture
la femme dont je vous parle ne gagnent
pas suffisamment pour avoir un logement
aujourd'hui il n'a plus que l'alcoolisme
pour oublier la solitude et l'amour que
lui porte son chien pour oublier la
violence permanente
elle travaille mais ce soir encore elle
dormira dans la rue pourtant ces
personnes pourraient s'en sortir grâce
aux aides auxquelles elles ont droit
enfin c'est ce que nous pensons pour
pouvoir bénéficier des aides il faut
avoir un compte bancaire pour avoir un
compte bancaire
il faut avoir une paix identité pour
avoir une petite quantité il faut avoir
un logement
tout part de là logement conditionne
tout sans logement pas de droit au
respect de la vie privée a droit à la
santé
pas de droit à la sécurité en somme pas
de dignité
deux cent mille deux cent mille c'est le
nombre de personnes qui ont dû renoncer
à cette dignité pendant des mois nous
avons parcouru les villes à la recherche
des témoignages des sdf
afin de mieux comprendre les raisons qui
font de chacun des personnes de la rue
partout les raisons qui poussent à la
rue sont différentes
c'est une constante inexorable au cours
de sa vie un homme ou une femme risque
plusieurs fois la rue
les causes sont multiples chômage de
longue durée peine de prison mal suivis
ou un handicap quelconque
en revanche nous n'avons trouvé que peu
de différence sur les raisons qui
obligent chacun à rester dans la rue le
système administratif dans son ensemble
ne semble pas fournir d'incitants
suffisant pour permettre aux personnes
de s'en sortir système administratif
trop froid trop complexe interlocuteurs
trop nombreux une fois à la rue
l'émiettement de l'espoir semble
inexorable pourtant c'est contre le sort
de toutes ces personnes que l'ugtt
l'état les associations et les
politiques publiques successives alors
une question se pose
de qui est ce la faute avant de trouver
le fautif dressons constat c'est simple
tout augmente le nombre des sdf
dispositif d'aidé aux sdf la perte
d'espoir des sdf tout augmente
ils sont deux cents mille aujourd'hui
dans la rue une armée silencieuse sans
banderoles pour manifester leur colère
ni revendication ils étaient moitié
moins il ya 20 ans deux cent mille c'est
toute la ville de rennes dans la rue
tout augmente
longue de décret de loi de création
d'organismes d'associations qui voulait
résoudre le problème sortir les gens de
la rue et qui n'a rien résolu
le sdf malgré lui est le plus grand
créateur d'acronymes rsa dalle au chu
s'est ému ccc cscs apa il est
aujourd'hui éligibles à près de 30 est
différente mais beaucoup ne touche
aucune
c'est un millefeuille administratif au
goût amer indigeste et qui ne nourrit
pas son homme
tout augmente les dépenses de l'état
pour la prise en charge des sdf
elles ont doublé en 20 ans c'est logique
me diriez vous le nombre de sdf double
les aides de l'état double également
mais pourtant les aides de l'état ont
pour objectif de réduire le nombre de
sdf en les doublant on aurait pu espérer
diminuer le nombre de sdf et ensuite dit
mieux les dépenses de l'état
on a vu tout inverse c'est le tonneau
des danaïdes plus se remplie d'argent
puis les bears dans nos rues de nouveaux
sdf
tout augmente le désespoir quand
l'espoir c'est niet
si sdf sur 10 tu appelles +115 nous même
plus le courage de demander un logement
philippe varin appelle cela le phénomène
de non concernés mans c'est le fait de
perdre la notion même d'avoir des droits
le système favorise le renoncement comme
pour ulysse les vents sont souvent
contraire il souffre des papiers à
remplir des attestations a délivré des
abrets s'adonner qui les repoussent
petit à petit loin du rivage du salut on
a tous peinés de vin document cerfa
imaginer un sdf sur le soupirail bouche
de métro en train de remplir les siens
en fin de compte on organise la
précarité puisque on la combat
un soir en plein mois de décembre dans
la gare de rennes nous rencontrons
jean-luc jean-luc fait partie de ces sdf
pour qui les années ont effacé une part
d'identité
il a à peine un prénom même plus d'image
cette photo est issue d'une banque
d'imagés libres de droits
nous expliquons à jean-luc notre
démarche
cette volonté d'élargir notre vision et
nous donne les clefs de lecture afin
afin de mieux comprendre le système d
aide aux plus pauvres
en prenant ses propres exemple pour le
son jean-luc incarnée par sa place dans
le système
l'organisation de la précarité il me
semblait plus croire en la capacité des
politiques publiques à pouvoir l'en
sortir et nous a raconté son histoire
il était né il ya une cinquantaine
d'années avec une déficience mentale qui
l'avait obligé à vivre jusqu'à sa
majorité dans un établissement
spécialisé au jour de ses 18 ans
l'établissement brûle et jean-luc perd
plusieurs de ses camarades dans
l'incendié il se retrouve alors dehors
sans que ne demeure aucune prise en
charge
l'absence de suivi à l'époque ne lui a
pas permis et de demander les droits qui
lui était dieu ni de lancer les appels à
l'aide nécessaire s'est il encore qu'il
a des droits
il semble difficilement en avoir
conscience la pierre angulaire du
déficit de ce système
c'est l'absence d'information jean-luc
nous l'a expliqué et les chiffres nous
l'ont démontré
savez vous que 30% des sdf souffre d'un
trouble psychique sévère bipolarité
schizophrénie dépression sévère mais que
seuls 7 % d'entre eux bénéficient de
l'allocation adulte handicapé comment
trouver de l'espoir dans un système où
d'une part la présence de troubles
psychiques aggrave et favorise la
précarité et la rue et où d'autres par
la présence dans la rue est allongée et
pérenniser du fait de l'existence même
de ces troubles psychiques
ce cercle vicieux est un exemple parmi
tant d'autres des obstacles auxquels
fait face la population des sdf
pourtant le système doit être salué ils
versent 1875 euros par mois d'argent
public à chaque sdf mais il présente de
graves insuffisances division son
fonctionnement en étapes d'abord le
législateur celui qui fait la loi décide
de déclarer une guerre de principe
contre la pauvreté puis dans un second
temps le conseiller local celui du
guichet social doit pour attribuer les
aides créée par cette loi se référer à
une multitude de dispositifs complexes
le premier problème apparaît donc la
grande parole théorique et abstraite de
celui qui fait la loi celle qui vise à
dire par exemple qu'il n'y aura plus de
sdf dans les rues avant la fin avant la
fin de l'année cette parole là c'est
depuis dans la réalité par une multitude
de dispositifs dont la complexité pour
le sdf n'est pas toujours appréhendé par
le législateur autre problème la
relation entre le conseiller et le sdf
elle est profondément inégalitaire elle
se situe toujours sur un registre
technique
le rendez vous impose une temporalité
contraignante et le sdf fait face à une
multitude d'interlocuteurs toujours
différents alors celui qui fait la loi
constatant la faible efficacité des
moyens mis en oeuvre au regard de leur
trop grande complexité décide à nouveau
de déclarer une guerre de principe
contre la pauvreté avec de nouveaux
objectifs
et l'histoire se répète nous avons
rapidement compris la vision que
jean-luc avec ce système comme un ulysse
ali tac inatteignable privé à jamais du
confort d'un foyer et de la chaleur de
ses proches
pourtant un nouveau paradigme est
possible un nouveau paradigme est
possible si l'on sort de la logique dans
laquelle on lutte seulement contre le
fléau de la précarité sans jamais la
chasse est un nouveau paradigme est
possible si on décide de passer au delà
de la simple bataille du symbole et que
l'on son porche
concrètement sur les droits et les aides
que l'on attribué à chacun ainsi nous
répond sur yon la manière d'appréhender
la pauvreté en france
retrouver un logement et le dernier
palier de la non escaliers pour le
gravir pas d'ascenseur mais de
nombreuses marches cir est glissante et
des remous lui que seule une poignée
d'entre eux parvient les gravir chaque
marche d'un dispositif dead la première
ces logements d'urgence
la deuxième un logement transitoire et
la troisième le graal c'est logement
social la progression est lente
les chutes sont nombreuses alors on
recommence l'ascension c'est une liste
de la rue mais des années rentrer chez
eux
la logique est dit incitative on te
donne un logement mais que pour une
courte durée
cinq mois pour faire tes preuves sinon
tu repars à la case départ la rue
l'erreur de notre système est de faire
du logement un but ultime un horizon
lointain si dures à reconquérir
car sans logement point de salut tout
part de là toute vie sociale et
professionnelle dépend d'un chez soi
ces dures à reconquérir le logement
conditionne tous nos droits notre
dignité
or le système est un cercle vicieux où
le logement est à la fois la ligne
d'arrivée est l'unique moyen de la
franchir nous proposons alors de
renverser la logique de faire du
logement non pas le point d'arrivée de
ce long chemin de croix
mais le point de départ de la
socialisation de faire du logement non
plus une finalité mais un moyen
un moyen de sortir de la misère notre
proposition s'inspire de ce que fait la
finlande
elle procure à tous les sdf un logement
pour une durée indéterminée et sans
condition ils peuvent alors à l'abri des
mots de la rue reconstruire
progressivement le fil de leur vie
cette politique est un véritable succès
la finlande fait des économies
dix mille euros par an et par sdf en
frais de santé en l'intervention de
police et en aide sociale les délais de
réinsertion sont plus courts et les
rechutes moins nombreuses en guise de
conclusion jean luc nous avait dit et si
finalement ce n'est pas le système
lui-même qui nous maintenaient dans une
condition d'assister face à cette
société qui nous condamnent comme des
assistés un nouveau modèle est possible
une alternative peut voir le jour le
modèle du logement avant tout logement
comme un moyen et non comme une finalité
mais pour réussir ce changement nous
devons tous changer notre manière de
percevoir les sdf il faut passer d'une
logique d'apitoiement à une logique de
soutien et d'assistance et de
réinsertion
sans cela nous resterions dans une
politique qui maintient à la surface de
la pauvreté et qui se refuse à la
chasser définitivement
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]